were you down there when norm passed
away
yeah that was awful norm was one of my
best friends
that was awful really yeah that was my
buddy todd calling i woke up from a nap
and i look at my phones my friend todd
i'm like hey what's up
he goes uh we're just taking a nap and i
go yeah what's up
he goes uh you haven't checked your
phone have you and i go no
and he goes norm mcdonald died
and i go
what no
and he goes yeah and it was one of the
few times in my life
i just hung up the phone and immediately
started sobbing
and i sobbed for like a half hour i just
completely lost it yeah he was like
really like one of my close friends and
it was like waiting for a fight huh it
was awful dude it was just and then i
found out like he had cancer for a long
time didn't tell anybody and it it was
hard it's still really hard everyone's
pretty shook by it do you remember the
last time that you had seen him
um i hadn't seen him for a while
but uh the last time i saw him
was that like at a bar by our place
and uh
he would watch he was a big gambler
but um the last time i talked to him
i was quoting when i was quarantined in
minnesota he would uh i'd text him and i
go
hey what's up dude and he goes ah what
who's this
and i he would do this all the time i go
it's [ __ ] nick dude he goes
ah nikki
what uh what are you doing
and i'm like nothing quarantined and he
goes uh he didn't stand after
and i'm like no
the [ __ ] i wasn't doing stand up
and he goes why that what's your plan
and i go i don't know i'm gonna kick it
here and then i think i'm gonna go to
key west and i go
i might just retire though and just move
to reno and just get like a residency
and then i'll just live in reno and just
work there just be like an old comic
yeah and he goes the sword of god he
goes
ah that's a that's a good idea i'm gonna
go yeah i don't know whatever he goes
that nah
uh maybe i'll join you we'll both
headline reno
and i go
dude reno's [ __ ] a mess
i go no i don't want to do it
so i go to key west a month later he
calls him he goes hey
what are you doing
and i go i don't know i'm in key west
what's up with you and he goes
uh
when are you going to reno and i go
dude that was a joke i'm not moving to
[ __ ] reno and retiring it's like a
comic and he goes ah [ __ ] i thought i
thought it was a good idea
and i'm like no
and so that's the last time i talked to
him
and then his
um close close for his closest friend
lori joe
i hit her up after norman passed and i
was like hey are you doing okay
and she goes one of the last things
before
norm died one of the last things he
talked about was moving to reno with you
no yeah and i go are you serious she
goes yeah he was like
he really wanted to do that
and i was like oh that made me cry again
and uh yeah it was just
that was norm it was really awful damn
i'll tell you i have so many norm
stories but this is one of my favorites
and um
i was on tour me sandler spade rob
schneider and norm was kind of like the
wild card he would pop in for certain
dates
so we're and uh believe mohican sun in
connecticut and we're backstage
everyone's in samuel's green room
talking shooting [ __ ] and me and norman
in the hallway hanging out and um i
don't know why i did this
uh this long hallway and this guy walks
in
uh way down the hallway walks in the
door
and i'm like looking and you know we're
always kind of suspicious about people
who come backstage
and i go
i think that guy's a gun
and uh norma goes
what
and i go i think that guy's a [ __ ]
gun dude and he's like oh my god and he
runs into sandler's room and he goes
there's a gun
there's a man with a gun and i was like
no no no there's not there's not i was
no no i'm joking there's not and he goes
next time there's a guy with a gun and
stanley goes what the [ __ ] is this guy
with a [ __ ] gun and spade's like oh
no what the [ __ ] what's good and i'm
like no there's no gun there's no gun i
just it was i was making like a joke
just for norm and norm's like
how is that a joke and i'm like i don't
i don't know
and sam was like
stanley was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and i'm like
i don't know man spade's like yeah real
cool man and i'm like
i'm just going to go to my room
and norm's like yeah i thought there was
a gun i'm sorry nick nick said it
i'm like
lord real buzz and the guy walked past
it was a security guard
[Laughter]
but yeah so he really did have a gun
he didn't have a gun but he just looked
like somebody that would have a gun
yeah well people use guns for security
man
it was just not a good joke on my part
especially poor norm did you guys ever
work together or not
we did those shows together and we did
like
oh i got a normal story too um you know
we never like we're on stage together
like [ __ ] bonnie and clyde or whoever
i had to go to this casino one time with
norm right
gambling no he was playing on the show
adam eager was there and i somehow got
booked in the feature right
so norm's headline and
i felt like norm was on pills or he was
a little bit lit but i don't know if
that's true some people say he never did
any drugs i don't know he seemed like he
was off he did he took pills but he
could have been yeah he could have just
been having a this was like he had
cancer for a while right so who knows uh
i don't even know
so but this is when i was alive and you
know in my past
so what happened was i
go on stage and i ran the light right i
was like
and it was literally in a barn like
attached to a casino like the place you
could hear like there were like live
births like there was a lot going on you
know from animals or people i mean who
knows you know thick things you just
heard the sludge oh you hurt you heard
some [ __ ] sludge you heard you let the
bodies hit the floor there was nobody
catching these things they were being
born right you know it was just a lot of
uh
falling they were free falling
and then they would hit the ground not a
skinny puppy you know a lot of babies
that were fart powered oh yeah
that's my son you know oh a little robo
fart yes that kind of
so who books this gig helen keller
so anyway
he goes out there and he's he is like
you can barely even hear him it's bad
he's just kind of garbling his words
right right so
anyway
the next day
we're all downstairs jerry mathers is
there too
okay what
no i swear jerry mathers is beaver from
leave it to be bring him a picture jerry
mathers please also that's a real show
for all the kids out there leaves called
leave it to beaver yeah and beaver was
like the rascal son right oh all show
old shows are porns now right there he
is right there
yeah
and uh what the [ __ ] was he doing giving
birth
eddie haskell bro he was the same show
and yeah eddie haskell died recently
r.i.p very sad but um young violence uh
i'm not sure what it was i think it was
miss live in a nice neighborhood i think
it was miss applebaum or whatever he
whoever the teacher was he was always at
odds with you know yeah miss crab apple
or whatever it was but anyway uh so i
get up i i i get up there um oh in the
morning
oh so mathers is there right and i said
to him i was like he's like i was just
talking i was a huge fan i had signed i
bought an autographed picture of him
when i was a kid i had it on my wall at
home i had a jerry mathers autographed
picture in the wallet that is gross
because his name was theodore and my
name theodore oh that's right so i was
just keyed in right so anyway
uh
i don't wish this story would end
you were like leave it to sleazer dude
so anyway i'm [ __ ] throwing on your
[ __ ] eggnog
where do you live
i said i live in santa monica he goes i
used to get some [ __ ] in santa monica
that's exactly what he said bro
so right there i'm a little shook i'm
excited you know i'm still excited that
it's him but i'm a little shook right
but anyway in the morning norm's
downstairs we all have to play in this
poker tournament that's part of the
weekend deal the package
and norm's like man a lot of hot chicks
here hun i'm looking around it's like
nobody's
that nobody's hot in this area right
there hasn't been anybody hot here if
somebody here were hot you would know
about it immediately maybe on a calendar
they would be on the news yeah they
would feel the news yeah
yeah that would be on the news bro
yeah if a decent strand of jeans pass
through this town the [ __ ] fire
alarms would go off right there has not
been they would be up from the news to a
milk carton in like a week there has not
been a a unique strand of gtac to roll
through this area
in [ __ ] says [ __ ] what norm was
definitely on pills if he was like
looking around there right ah there's
some
tailing yeah so i thought he was serious
right because i don't really know him
i'm like yeah man there definitely is
and then he goes [ __ ] no there is
this shook me
that's that's so him that's amazing
he like baited me into believing that he
yeah and then [ __ ] pulled the rug out
did he [ __ ] no there isn't it's so hard
she never i mean i was one of his good
friends for
a long time i'm talking like 15 years
wow and i still was like
i could kind of gauge but sometimes i
was like
what is he saying right but he he was
out of his
out of this world and did he chase a lot
of women did he have a wife or anything
no
i never met a wife he has a son dylan
who's really cool so he must have did
sex once at least i mean i never saw he
was addicted he was a big gambler dude
really yeah
and he
he had a bit
he
he always had so many gay jokes but i
never knew him to be gay or anything but
he had a joke he was on letterman
and uh or no it was conan and he goes
he is promoting his book and he says
yeah it's not a memoir but uh
and it's just uh it's a book
and he goes uh
you know i don't talk about being deeply
a deeply closeted gay man and conan goes
what you're gay and he goes what
now why'd you say that because we just
said he goes now i'm i'm deeply closeted
and he goes so you're not good he's like
no no i'm straight as an arrow
he goes and then he goes and i'm
paraphrasing forgive me but he goes you
know deeply closeted means the guy is
gay but he's so gay you won't admit it
he hides it
and uh he's like yeah no i'm straight
it was such a [ __ ] good bit again i
[ __ ]
uh paraphrased it but it's on youtube
that's funny man yeah he was great
yeah i watched one of his clips and he
was on i think the view did you see that
clip no when they're trying to get him
to like he's trying to be very realistic
the show's like ultra liberal and he's
just trying to be just a realist like
yeah that's how he was yeah and they're
like they won't they're like you'll
never be back on this show they're all
joking about it and stuff anyway he
wouldn't because he wasn't like just
kind of conforming to whatever like
i don't know just some ridiculous story
why would they have him on i don't know
that's so weird like he's so not i can
see him doing it like if they offered it
to him but i can't here we go let's get
a little bit of it that uh uh the
democrats don't steal the election from
the uh the winner you know but who knows
[Music]
you like george bush i love george bush
man he's a good man decent you know none
of this
[Applause]
and he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the see
i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a a a fresh start because we don't
want any more murderers i think we
should just go on to the next question
oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah you
know
you're not awesome but i have no
accusations
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either i'm being very
nice okay
[Music]
and i don't want to hear it and this is
not the place to make those accusations
and you're supposed to be funny
there you go this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara so i'm not going to ask the next
question i thought it was a matter of
record
okay let me do this okay
they don't even want to talk about the
fact that maybe the guy murdered
somebody
[Applause]
let's talk football all right
manslaughter
[Laughter]
he's doubling down yeah i don't have
norm doesn't play by rules dude that's
hilarious
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one